is elton a good friend of yours i mean
this guy calls you every day to check up
on you that sounds incredibly great my
wife had our daughter
and then elton started ringing me like
once a week because he's a father and he
wanted to check out i was getting on and
he loved seeing
lyra on facetime and blah blah blah
and then uh michael died and elton knows
michael or knew michael
and um
wrung me up the day afterwards and i
i i'm sure i'm sure you've had
close friends die as well but you get to
a point where you will just be having a
conversation like this and then you just
stop talking and then you just burst out
crying for like five seconds and then
you pull yourself back together and do
that and over the conversation that must
have happened like
three or four times and uh
from that that point he just rung me
every single day um just to check up on
me because he knew that i was having a
full-on time with that and it hasn't
stopped i'm not saying it's like a long
chat like we don't like catch up in full
every day he rings me for like 30
seconds
he'll we'll talk about something like at
the moment his album came out last week
and i was ringing him being like oh my
god man it's going number one like
congratulations and you know he's
excited about that and then this week
it's it's it's my record and he's
calling me about we've done a christmas
song together so we're we're trying to
work out a music video and a performance
of it and
blah blah blah but yeah he does call me
every single day and i absolutely love
him what a lovely relationship i mean
this is one of the you know again one of
the greatest musicians that's ever lived
and to i'm sure it's a you know you
picture yourself
i think i i th this is the thing there's
two different people right there's elton
john the performer and everyone knows
and loves elton john the performer but
no one really knows the true
heart of this bloke because i'm not the
only person he does this to he has this
relationship with so many people that
he's close to and he gives advice to and
he's there for a mentor i know he has
the same with brandy carlyle
right i know i know he has the same with
gaga like he's he's just he's just a
wonderful wonderful human and he's
constantly plugged into music he gets
all the new releases every single week
and he's ringing me about artists he
wrote me about kid leroy two years ago
and he's like keep an eye out for kid de
roy is going to be the biggest thing in
the world and what happens two years
later he's the biggest thing in the
world and yeah he said to you when one
of these conversations says hey ed
you ought to mentor other artists sign
other artists and stuff and the story i
heard was um you said you know you took
that to heart
and uh you you you tried to sign sean
mendes who has certainly blown up to be
a big star and shawn mendes was what
like 15 at the time when you tried to
sign him
why didn't shawn mendes sign with you he
was already down the road with the right
the record label that he he'd signed to
he was he knew the guys he was
comfortable with them and i'm not i'm
not going to use the card of like hey
but yeah i'm
this actor blah blah blah because like
what if i can't do a better job than
them i want him to have a career i don't
want him to have a career if it's under
me
um
so yeah it was
but but that's but that's happened to me
loads of times man there's loads of
artists that i know that
i could sort of you dip your toe in a
little bit and go do you like would you
be open to it and then if there's
even a hint of oh but this might be a
better home for me i kind of like back
off um wow
what but this is the thing with with
with ellen elton's a mentor elton's not
this like megalomaniac who has to
elton's not finding kid leroy two years
ago right and then being like right i'm
gonna sign you and have two percent of
you or whatever because i have to earn
earn off it he just finds artists that
he loves
and then tells people about them because